we have an interesting question on our
quiz where the majority was wrong it's
about convolutions and the difference
between invariance and a key variance
translational or shift invariance means
that irrespectively of the position of a
cat the output of the convolution
operation is the same which it isn't
since the feature map still reflects the
original position so this is actually a
key variance because when the position
of the cat changes the output changes in
the same way reflecting shift and with
the sliding kernel this is exactly what
happens so convolutions are not shift
invariant but ecky variant if you got
this wrong it's okay because these words
are used interchangeably in language
except of highly mathematical contexts
please mind that the question asks about
the convolution only it was the next
day's trick question
inquiring about the cnn as a whole while
convolutional layers do not make the cnn
shift invariant but only eki variant it
takes spatial pooling layers to make it
approximately shift invariant by pushing
information that was far away into
approximately the same spot